what's the next plan asking what are you
looking for okay huh what a coincidence
okay let's sketch this you can see it
asks for all three in graphs my advice
is to do them on separate axes because
it's gonna get really busy really fast
let's just draw some Norfolk okay right
just as you continue to draw those you
can see and it's the lovely thing about
simple harmonic motion and how
predictable it is right you've just
started with a sine function it starts
at the origin because your faith is no
phase shift to worry about okay so there
I am all I need to worry about in terms
of actual scale and points that Tommy
with that kind of thing they're all
things we worked out in Parts A and B
right have a look what's the period
that's the period we answered this
before right it's two seconds so that is
all the way through to a whole cycle of
motion that makes that two which makes
this middle point one I can y'all
complicated and we also define the
amplitude because we entered it over
here so you've got four and five
negative for environment now everything
else when you have a look at your
velocity and the acceleration functions
the pieces are the same I'm even going
to use the same physical scale but I'm
just gonna label the axes differently
right your time axis it still obey the
same thing nothing has changed to your
horizontal you okay so this is still -
and this is still one but I am
interested to you that I'd better talk
about what I did to sense about this
it's just a half and one and a half
right or three or two that's fine okay
there intercept so I better put in one
and I also need to know the amplitude
but when did I wake that out
I worked it out in Potsie right maximum
speed that's from Spain that's gonna be
the positive one and there's the
negative one
yeah okay and lastly you still make 0 1
& 2 but your amplitude now is there it
is there's my maximum acceleration okay
for pi and negative 4 pi okay so this
looks good let's look at our final two
parts they're just asking about
particular instances of where the object
is and what it's doing at those times so
you can see part a it says find the next
two times the particle is at the origin
and the velocities event now what this
is really do is just can you read the
graph solace asking okay we in fact the
kind of answer bit they have to say next
two times at the origin because when we
firstly origin times zero okay so when
they say next two times and clearly main
not this one but this guy this guy yeah
which we've already put on because we
did a good job at graphic okay so honey
next two times and origin
they also judges asked us when but
because we're still in academic context
what's the velocity at those time have a
look look there's one of there's two
right which correspond to the extremes
here and here
remember why do you remember why do you
remember when we were doing this all
right when my object has gone to extreme
the motion it momentarily stops it's
stationary for a split second and then
as it comes past and it moves back to
back past the origin rather it's moving
at the fastest it possibly can
there and there does that make sense so
they have asked to for velocity not
speed so my sign that is when time is
equal to one what is the policy and and
at time two you just need to know oh
it's the other one right it's in the
opposite direction okay last ones read
it and you can see what you need to
interpret which graph you need to go for
right find the first two times the
particle is stationary and the
acceleration then so to answer party
right we focused on displacement and the
whole city back at these two to answer
this next question we're still gonna
look at two graphs we're gonna look at
these two right find the two times it's
the pike was stationary where's that but
I've got I've got literally the point of
where it's stationary and I've even
labeled what they are so I'm going to
say next two times when it's sorry is it
next two times first two times
time equals tiny things okay what are
our times that's okay
and each case I'm looking now for the
acceleration which again since these are
the extremes of motion they're the only
points where you're paused right that
means you're looking for the most
extreme values of acceleration which in
fact we've already answered we've
already answered this I just need to
know restriction though because
acceleration has a sign that equals 1/2
and here it's the a nice easy way you
can concur confirm that rather is at T
equals 1/2 a second displacement wise
where are you where are you which side
of the origin are you want you are above
you're on the positive side displacement
wise which means according to it off
according to the differential equation
for sublime one mission if you're on the
positive side then the acceleration has
to be in the opposite direction and vice
versa ok yes ok so you can see this is
not a pumpkin this is OK the craziest
things are when they maybe change the
center of motion because your
differential equation get that little
bit more complicated but I think you
guys will be fine again the calculus is
not difficult like this just sort of
rushes by and it's all about
interpretation ok